and you know if you did have your past
job I don't think I would be under oath
but more importantly let's go to rod
Rosenstein this is a guy he signed the
fourth warrant which was the bulk of
information was that phony Russian
dossier paid for by Clinton they didn't
tell the FISA Court judges they didn't
verify the information they didn't
follow the law they didn't follow up
behind protocol and Rada Rosenstein
signed the last one the third renewal
the fourth all together your reaction
well there's no doubt that rod
Rosenstein deserves everything that he's
getting whether or not impeachment is
the right way to go doesn't even matter
anymore Rosen Stein remembered didn't
even read the final application he had
people explain to him what was in it
Rosen Stein is the one responsible for
the crisis that the president has faced
in the Muller probe without Rosenstein
there is no Muller probe he did it
purposely to avoid having to make
difficult decisions in a political
investigation he should be ashamed of
himself he's getting precisely what he
deserves but what's more important than
that Shawn is that you are watching a
President of the United States who is
astride the globe and he is being
assisted Abele by a Secretary of State
in full we no longer have a namby-pamby
foreign policy we have a Secretary of
State who today performed beyond any
expectations any Americans could expect
of a Secretary of State I was amazed at
pompey's performance and I can tell you
say the president is really pleased
especially because of the outrageous
performance of the Director of National
Intelligence dan coates in Aspen when he
kissed the feet of Andrea Mitchell and
criticized the President of the United
States
shame on dan coats I watched Pompeo
today and I literally felt fabulous no
fabula geez
finally strength and he laid out all the
things that the president nBC though I
think reported that he's an agent of
Russia is doing to Russia but the irony
to here is look we cannot ignore
I gotta get you take on this Pfizer
listen if I like to a FISA judge or I
lied to any judge you couldn't get me
out of jail as great an attorney as you
are if I did this is this this is this
case is over what Sean this case is over
the FBI under Obama and the Department
of Justice under Obama with John Carlin
the assistant attorney general for
national security lied to the FISA Court
hid material information from the FISA
Court it is an outrageous abuse of power
and if Jeff Sessions and rod Rosenstein
have not begun a grand jury to
investigate all the people involved in
the phony dossier and everything
involved on it ultimately when Muller is
done Rosenstein and session should be
fired this is a clear case of criminal
law violation in the FISA application it
was clearly a fraud committed on the
FISA Court and it is beyond belief that
nothing publicly known has been done to
hold accountable everybody involved in
the signing of those applications in the
FISA Court